have you ever seen a guy talking about
semen retention you were like man I bet
that dude could get a lot of women no no
no [ __ ] no never no oh see my
retention song look people in the eye
dude I'll Jack it right now shake you
were in the hand no problem don't even
wash them off
the semen retention he didn't entertain
anything take a wild guess
it's when you you hold hold it in is it
celibacy basically but like nothing like
nothing at all yeah that's what some
people do that celibacy no no no no no
no nothing no Lonesome nights
imagining things yeah no nothing yeah
yeah so that's what it is that's a big
thing in the red pill space is guys
promote semen retention and stuff
because it like raises testosterone
makes you tougher keeps you more on edge
stuff like that I've heard that a a
conversation around that worry like it
makes you it it recycles that energy and
and you use it in other ways there must
be something to taking that frustration
and it no 100 taking it out if you get
no [ __ ] and you're there jerking it
every night and then you force yourself
to not do it then I mean I like to say
it would get you in the gym more because
you if you want to get girls you have to
do something about it rather than just
jerking off every night and also you
need to get that frustration out
somewhere so we might as well take it
out doing push-ups or some [ __ ] yeah I
hate high value I hate alpha male I hate
all that [ __ ] I know it's a placeholder
but to me it's a man he knows who he is
he's taking care of his business in his
finances Fitness his health his style I
even think to some degree it can even be
vulnerable if they jump to take
advantage of it you'll make them pay I
don't mind that I like that that I hate
high value he's the labels are just more
stupid [ __ ] that we assign just be
you don't need you need a label just be
it that's it it gives a [ __ ] what
anybody calls you I like that I like his
attitude on that one okay I see tall
guys all the time I'll be back home or
something be standing in line at Walmart
and I'll look over and there'll be some
guy in like plant clothes six two
scraggly ass looking beer fat as [ __ ] J
blue eyes I'm like that [ __ ] if
he lost that weight he will [ __ ] slay
it glad his fat ass doesn't or for me I
don't care but I see I see that [ __ ] all
the time man it's like there's wasted
Talent all these guys you know they
think that just because you know they're
not Brad Pitt that they can't get women
I think Andrew says this I said you can
either be handsome or you can look scary
so you have the option because you can
be big and strong and maybe a little
ugly but if you do well and then respect
you and Men follow you you're confident
there's too many beautiful women out
there for you to have an excuse not to
be able to do it I see it all the time
too I see exactly what he sees I see
Sloppy out of shape lazy looking dudes
and I can see under that and be like if
only you took care of yourself die man
like what are you doing yeah I have
friends from home that just like let
themselves go and when they were younger
and their metabolism's higher and they
were skinnier they were getting girls
and now it's for the life of them gave
up gave up it's crazy though it's like
what are you doing drinking every night
getting baked all the time when you look
like [ __ ] dude don't you have like
you're terrible probably one of the
reasons but like yeah girls are a pretty
damn good reason to motivate you they're
a good that's a good motivator is it not
and then there's all the other reasons
like you know not having diabetes and
and heart disease that's a pretty good
one so having a healthier mind you know
when you're doing [ __ ] all the time and
getting [ __ ] up every day waking up
not tired as well said yeah higher above
yourself so let me give you an example
let's say a guy's working for me he's
putting up buildings for me he's like
I'm making Justin all this [ __ ] money
and I'm getting paid this blah blah blah
so we leave and he goes out and it's
just him and his little crew and they
build a building and he makes some good
money and he goes and builds another
building he does it again and all of a
sudden people start to hear about him
and he starts having to need more than
one crew and then he needs three crews
well the next thing you know he can't be
on job B because he's on job a and then
job C is going on over here with job B
got put up wrong and so now the roof's
leaking and because the roof's leaking
they won't pay you so he goes over he
tries to fix the leak and he's starting
to get burnt out and then he goes over
the building scene he's got the same
thing going on then he gets some cash
flow pitch next thing you know bam boom
he's out if I was anybody today I would
say okay which of the three am I and
what do I need to hire to make sure that
I don't find myself in an overwhelming
role as a technician or manager or
whatever you have to identify which one
of those positions you are and then hire
somebody that can do those things the
last thing you need in your business is
somebody else like you that's a good
point you don't want to like Alpha
leaders in the business you need the guy
that's there taking control of [ __ ] and
then the people that do the tasks I'm
going to manage other people to do tasks
it's a good point but I love that hit
this quote here don't be scared to hire
above yourself
like
and then and this is absolutely true
like I would love to hire somebody to
just run [ __ ] and just let me do
the [ __ ] I enjoy
and that I know I'm good at yeah and you
make sure that me and everyone else is
doing everything to meet the company's
goals yeah somebody that's good at that
he's absolutely right and this is you
know you and I talk about that though
like you're 19. you're running this
content creation you're running the gsda
you're running uh a tick tock and
YouTube Market or basically your content
marketing agency marketing for other
people you have a lot going on and it's
gonna get very quickly to a point where
you may need to do that you may need to
hire somebody above you or you may need
to become that guy and hire the right
people below you but you cannot do it
all and you can't pretend that you can
because nobody can oh yeah it's crazy
the pretty girl I'll walk up to her in
the grocery store and a lot of times I
already kind of know because women will
put themselves in your space yeah you
know what I'm saying that's how they run
game right yeah so they're not going to
come talk to you but if they put
themselves in your space and stay
because most of times if they see a man
they'll just [ __ ] Bolt yeah they'll
go around the store to go to the produce
section again just get the [ __ ] away
from you if they don't want to be around
you yeah the way I look at it is genuine
honesty so I'll walk up to a woman I'll
say hey excuse me I don't mean to be
rude but I would have been upset with
myself for being a coward and not come
speak to you yeah I think you're
beautiful my name is Justin absolutely
the way to go about it okay I'll do that
I'm gonna go to the grocery store I'm
gonna pick up some hoes how many times
have I told you that well okay yeah if a
woman's giving you signals like running
around the store getting away like yeah
clearly she doesn't want to talk to you
but if she has any interest in or at
least
isn't horrified by you she'll keep
herself in your space right so you know
you gotta you don't know which it is but
at least she's not horrified
beautiful girls men are afraid to talk
to them we've talked about this those
are the ones that you go up to and you
talk to them because nobody else talks
to them but the thing is they get so
much attention on Instagram nowadays
that now they're just [ __ ] in
person when you try to talk to them
because they just feel better than you I
have this blue check guy on Instagram
that I can hit up uh maybe so it is and
you're all not every beautiful girl is
on Instagram Sunny some of them are
still in the real world some of them
yeah what are the differences between
being a man trying to make it by herself
and hang around with a group of guys
like us well I felt very alone because
slowly as I stayed in shape and I
started to make more money and I stopped
getting invited to gender reveal parties
foreign
s are like bro he's bad boy I don't want
him around my husband I always say [ __ ]
time and [ __ ] blood I want to know do
our souls align I need to find people
that believe things that I believe that
want the same things that I want you
need to find a group of people that can
support you inside a tribe that's strong
enough to have your back all the way
around when you'll have true happiness
and you'll definitely have a true family
that's such a dope mindset right there
when I knew I was I stopped getting
invited to them [ __ ] and Matrix
gender reveal parties that's when I knew
I was doing the right thing that's a
killer that's so fast in fact when you
know I'm doing the right thing if these
people don't want me around anymore I'm
on to something yeah or if I'm getting
invited by people cooler than me and
then less invites from people lower than
me it's like you're obviously going in
the right direction common J Wall it's
an interesting thing though because for
me that that hits that hits at home for
me right now because we just moved to
Florida I've got [ __ ] wonderful
wonderful friends in Boston and around
the country because we've moved a lot so
just moving to Florida I've got family
here I've got cousins that's awesome and
I will always hang out with them almost
daily regularly but I want my own people
and so you know one of the things we're
doing is like we're going out you know
we're joining a gun range I'm looking
for the right church I was talking to
this writer that I know here
um
and I'm gonna go to that like it's gonna
take a lot of testing down in a new
environment to find my like my people
that I really want to hang with 100 but
it hits home if a girl really likes you
she doesn't care if you're eating steak
or corn dog bam straight up she'll meet
you anywhere do she'll do coffee she'll
do a walk in the park man she wants her
time so
um if you have a girl that you're
messaging let's say on social media or
something like that and she won't meet
you just for a simple ass coffee then
she doesn't like you bro thank you
straight up ask once he asked twice more
than that
um
no you can't be chasing no chasing no I
mean girls like to be chased a little
honestly we're not that there's a lot of
Muslims I'm chased because if we like a
guy we're like okay we're gonna jump
right into the Trap it's it's the truth
all I do a lot of muscle we have like
the little [ __ ] voice and then we have
a grown ass man voice so my goal is
always to smother the child voice is
that just lie to myself and I say look
I'm just gonna go in here and do one set
and leave a little [ __ ] is like okay
just one set and then we can go but yeah
we can go the next thing you know you
spend an hour because you get warmed up
you're like this isn't so bad or you
start to get a pump or whatever it is I
will manipulate myself and do [ __ ] that
I'm supposed to do such a such good
advice if you
don't want to go to the gym don't look
at it like you're going to the gym to do
an hour workout all you're doing is
putting on
on your running shoes or whatever and
you're stepping out the front door
that's all you're doing or you're
walking to the gym because by the time
you get to the gym oh I completed this
task am I gonna go in the gym workout or
am I gonna just go back home I'm already
here I'm already here yes I'm gonna get
more out of it
if you ever have like a big essay or
something or anything you have to work
on I'm just gonna sit down and work on
it for two minutes I'm gonna work on it
and focus full Focus for two minutes and
by the time that two two minutes is done
it's been 20 minutes you were focused
working oh I feel like I had played a
part in you thinking that way because
I've actually done that with you
recently like Hey listen I need some
help seven minutes seven minutes and
then you know you kind of get into
something after that you're right I'll
be like I need you for seven minutes to
help me rearrange the furniture and
you're mad
and then and then and you do and then at
like the six and a half minute Mark you
sometimes are like but shouldn't we also
do that and
you get into it and that's just the
truth if you could just say to yourself
I'm gonna go to the gym I'm gonna be
there for eight minutes and leave you're
gonna be there an hour and you're gonna
walk out it must be feeling better on my
sleep I'll let my girl go to church
I'm telling you because church is
nothing more than a Sunday morning Club
they got the Big G's or in the front so
I want 100 in the trade we're like the
dudes in the back or something like five
dollars the girls room open so approach
there too see the dirty old man walking
up to the single girls like God put it
on my heart to come speak to you
[ __ ] trying to get [ __ ] man
that's not [ __ ] man that's why he's
laughing hey man they separate the men
in the winter yeah
absolutely man the church is a big
[ __ ] difference
look at like Six Flags over Jesus
probably really like get down with like
full [ __ ] stereo systems
I went to today was like
it was as nice as some concert Halls
I've been in well Sunday morning
nightclub so where are you gonna say you
don't you're not a fan of Jay Waller
anymore Jay Waller I'm sorry jay I
cannot just say your name what is it
Justin Waller my name is Justin Waller
you want the best goals come near me
[Music]
hey can't argue with the man
wait a minute is he an architect yeah
shut up so there was my favorite book is
uh The Fountainhead by Anne Rand and uh
Howard Rorke is a ginger who's a
brilliant architect what would you give
Justin Waller uh one to ten it's an
overall rating you give him an eight
yeah
so thank you guys so much for watching
that was a good video with Justin all
right guys
[Music]
[Music]